it has been two days since that ccsd
five day pause ended tonight questions
remain if the days off made any
difference how many teachers and
students are actually out so eight news
now reached out to the district for
those answers but they tell us the
counting data is only released on a
weekly basis here's mary jane belly has
it telling us why some parents are
worried about the number accuracy and
the impact of ongoing absences
following the five-day pause teacher and
student absence numbers district-wide
will be available on a weekly basis
while they get daily data i asked for
those numbers assistant superintendent
dr monica cortez says weekly reports are
made available because there is not
enough staff to filter out daily numbers
so it'll look how is our staff
employing looking like every day it will
look at what is our absenteeism and then
is it something that is able to be
corrected by additional central office
going out to the schools or is it
something that we have to look at a
different plan for for instituting our
our instruction mom janae fernand
questions the accuracy of the numbers
she is still unable to reach the
district on the covet hotline or covet
form to report her daughter's absence we
kind of just did our notifications on
our own you know she talked to the the
cheerleaders and the people that she was
more
closely exposed to and
um
just to make sure that they knew derek
immig is a father of four he says the
number of absent teachers can be
unpredictable which impacts the kids
long term i've seen two letters from
charter schools vehemently claiming that
they're going to do everything they can
to keep our kids in school they're not
struggling with staffing right clark
county school district's another story
i've got a sophomore and i've got a
freshman neither one of them may have
experienced
a single day on campus under normal
conditions but they do hope we have
reached the coveted case peak and
schools could return to a new normal
mary jane balleza live local now
now we've also requested that weekly
data that we talked about we expect to
receive that report tomorrow and of
course we'll share it with you during
our daily newscasts